lo que parecía inminente ahora es una
realidad el sindicato de actores de
Hollywood entra en huelga así se une a
los guionistas de cine y televisión en
paro desde mayo la huelga comenzará Esta
media noche todos nosotros miembros del
sindicato dirigentes y personal
estaremos en las líneas de huelga mañana
por la mañana la huelga de 160.000
actores llega tras el fracaso de las
negociaciones con los estudios tanto los
actores como los guionistas exigen
aumentos en los salarios base y en los
salarios residuales al mismo tiempo de
mandar garantías de que su trabajo será
protegido de la Inteligencia artificial
llegamos con gran tristeza a esta
encrucijada
pero no teníamos otra opción
somos las víctimas aquí
prevé la interrupción de más programas y
películas la huelga de unos 11.500
guionistas interrumpe la mayor parte de
la producción de la temporada televisiva
de otoño y paraliza el rodaje de
películas de Gran presupuesto
la alianza de productores de cine y
televisión la asociación comercial que
negocia en nombre de Netflix waltístico
entre otras declaró estar decepcionada
de que se cancelen las negociaciones
Hollywood no presencia una huelga doble
desde hace más de 60 años entonces
actores y guionistas luchaban por los
ingresos residuales de las películas
vendidas a cadenas de televisión ahora
queda por ver cómo se solucionará el
conflicto en la época del streaming y la
Inteligencia artificial